et pour ceux 7,8 week-end j'ai trois
invités en plateau avec moi nouveau
bonjour bonjour pierre bun ce bonjour
jeanne françoise grandin et bonjour
emmanuel chauvin vous êtes en plateau
avec nous pour nous parler d'un
spectacle qui démarrent à partir de ce
vendredi soir mais pour ceux qui
manqueraient il ya le 6 il ya aussi le
12 le 13 le 19 le 20 octobre ouf plein
de fois au tour de vincent de paul
j'allais dire saint vincent de paul
c'était naturel de l'appeler ainsi qu'un
vent de ça vous parlez nous de ce
spectacle puisque là vous en aurez
remarqué que on mais vincent de paul
avec son orthographe civils et nos gars
nonick
alors pourquoi ce spectacle du notaire
doit parler de villepreux et les
environs et à villepreux vincent de paul
a été très présent ces 19 qu'il a acheté
1000 pr il a résidé dont il a résidé à
villepreux puisqu'il était précepteur
des enfants de gondi confesseur de
madame de gondi qu'était la châtelaine
de villepreux
il ya trois tableaux entre autres dans
le spectacle qui concerne
des faits qui se sont déroulés à vil
prix et puis il y à un autre aspect qui
est que aujourd'hui dans la société on
est amené à se poser du des questions
sur comment aider les plus défavorisés
effectivement j'avais au départ on a
parlé de vincent de paul et j'ai dit
spontanément saint-vincent-de-paul parce
qu'effectivement il est connu pour être
le serviteur des pauvres en tout cas
celui qui aidait les plus pauvres
absolument et on en a besoin voilà et
alors
l'idée c'est un peu de reprendre ce
qu'avait fait jean noël jeannet dans les
années 80 dans le monde ou par rapport à
un phénomène de société contemporains et
donner un éclairage historique
alors nous on fait un voyage dans le
temps on se retrouve au xviie siècle
avec un site extrêmement difficile
les formes d'immigration de l'époque
c'était avec les gars de 30 ans les
champenois qui voulait se réfugier à
paris mais pas que les paysans il y
avait aussi des nobles qui trouver à
paris à devoir faire le maul et donc il
y as eu
cette dimension là un éclairage
historique par rapport à une situation
que le reconnaît actuel incertain
spécialement des deux ans pour être
fait monter créé
deux ans non par adhésion avec une
trentaine de comédiens sont tous là il a
fallu écrire les textes parce que notre
volonté c'était de coller à la réalité
historique d'eau qui a eu un travail sur
des archives et puis après il a fallu
réunir l'ensemble de la compagnie
commedia musiciens les former puisque
tous à l'exception de moi même son désir
parce que je n'ai pas dit effectivement
vous êtes vous êtes comédiens vous et
archivistes historiens est aussi
comédien voilà vous avez été formé à
l'école nationale de théâtre de
strasbourg
est alors puisque vous parlez des
comédiens amateurs autour de nous on
trouve cette table il y en a deux jeanne
françoise grandin et emmanuel chauvin a
d'abord qu'est-ce qui vous a donné envie
de vous impliquer dans dans l'histoire
de saint vincent de paul chapelle saint
vincent de paul comme ça à tout d'abord
pour moi le xviie siècle c'est c'est un
siècle que j'aime bien
j'ai toujours aimé la figure de ceux de
vincent de paul
j' ai
était m'ont séduite par la qualité du
spectacle la qualité des textes par
toute la mise en scène au profit d'un
professionnalisme de pierre qui qui a
fait que j'ai bien voulu mais j'étais
attirée pour rentrer dans cette aventure
voilà et vous est manal chauvin alors
moi je le réitère je roule jouer en
effet je joue le rôle de bossuet mais
j'ai été impliqué dans le spectacle à un
stade très préliminaire puis c'était
avant le recrutement des acteurs entre
l'écriture d'ex pièces et le recrutement
des acteurs et donc je me suis impliqué
moi parce que je faisais des études
d'ingénierie culturelle et je voulais
vivre l'expérience de la création d'un
spectacle du point de vue des loges et
de fil en aiguille au tout départ oui
donc j'ai été très heureux trésorier de
l'association oblige aider à
l'organisation
1 et puis de fil en aiguille je suis
arrivé à endosser quelques rôles dont
celui de bossuet 1 ce qui n'était pas
prévu à la base mais ce qui a été une
expérience très enrichissante et donc
j'ai appris à redécouvrir ce que je
connaissais un peu aussi vincent de paul
et de voir cette connexion avec l'époque
d'aujourd'hui est donc on peut se dire
très facilement que oui il appartient à
notre un autre siècle mais en s'y
penchant on se rend compte de la
contemporanéité de son mot il est beau
je vais pas vous faire répéter merci
mais c'est un petit peu ce que vous
disiez c'est à dire que ça valait
toujours contemporain tout à fait donc
c'est si c'est une
spectacle on peut dire un spectacle
assez d'accord en douze tableaux qui
peut paraître peut-être un peu difficile
d'accès pour ceux qui ne portent pas la
foi ou en tout cas se disent
historiquement qui est trop qui est
saint vincent de paul c'est quand même
et c'est à sonner un personnage qui
aujourd'hui aurait sa raison à notre
époque je crois que chacun peut se
mettre en réseau noz par rapport à son
onze à son ses propositions et si vous
permettez je rajouterais c'est un
spectacle confessionnelles même s'il se
déroule et on album de se faire prêter
l'église dans laquelle vincent de paul a
prêché
c'est c'est très symbolique comme je
suis très fort ah oui ça va être
émotionnellement ça doit être fort voilà
à 3,65 quand on se dit qu'on joue dont
on joue une pièce autour de saint
vincent de paul à l'endroit même où il a
prêché voilà c'est aussi pour la raison
pour laquelle j'étais aussi j'ai accepté
de jouer parce que c'était un haut lieu
vincent sien c'était ville de villepreux
qui n'est pas forcément connu est le
fait de jouer dans cette danse est cette
belle église avec une belle acoustique
parce qu'il ya également il ya des il ya
des textes mais aussi des chants et a
donc c'est vraiment une joie nous il ya
trente comédiens cinq musiciens et les
shows nous les avons composé ensemble et
ce fut un grand bonheur donc j'ai des
trente comédiens s'amusent à syracuse
douze tableaux douze tableaux à
spectacle d'une heure et demie
avec berlin fois aussi des tableaux
extrêmement différent puisque quand
bossuet intervient il n'y a pas d'action
sans pensée et sans réflexion il ya les
fameuses conférences du mardyck et lieux
de ces intellectuels
parisiens qui se réunissent pour
débattre et c'est dans ces conférences
que bossue a été formé à l'art du
cerveau mais on a des tableaux avec des
enfants dont la fille matilda fille de
jane france et
deux au pied il ya énormément de deux
variétés mais ce qui nous semblait aussi
important c'est que ce ne soit pas
uniquement une dimension comédie
musicale au centre la pensée ce qui
nourrissait cette action là donc je
rappelle les dates 5 ce vendredi samedi
prochain pour ceux qui ne pourront pas
aller de sa fiche effectivement 12 13 19
et et 20 est ce qu'il y aura une vie
après encore le mois d'octobre est ce
que vous tapez d aider d'autres
peut-être lieu enfin d'autres églises
pour vous accueillir
on a des projets de représentation à
paris
pour le mois de janvier
on a déjà d'autres villes des yvelines
qui nous demande on doit finaliser le
tout mais on espère que cet
investissement quand même énorme 2 de 25
à 30 personnes travaillant pendant deux
ans dans les manifs l'association a été
créée pour ce spectacle
c'est à dire que le but de l'association
c'est par différents moyens de renforcer
l'identité vincent sienne de villepreux
et à côté de ça c'est bon t'es une
compagnie qui est la compagnie des vins
sancya qui sont les que médias mais vous
avez toutes les informations sur notre
site internet est très bien merci en
tout cas vous 3 d'être venu en plateau
donc je vous rappel pour ceux qui sont
curieux et intéressés par ce spectacle
autour de vincent de paul ce sera à
partir de ce vendredi soir en l'église
de villepreux et le spectacle dure tous
les week-ends jusqu'au 20 octobre merci
à vous trois